ABCs of AI R is for reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is a
type of machine learning that trains an
agent to make optimal decisions in an
environment by rewarding desired
behaviors and discouraging undesired
ones think of how children explore the
world around them and learn the actions
that help them achieve a goal it's based
on the idea of trial and error and over
time the agent learns to make the best
possible decisions in order to maximize
the reward Google cloud is using
reinforcement learning to optimize its
data ERS improve its recommendation
systems and develop new robotics
applications like self-driving cars and
delivery robots and now you know thanks
for tuning in to this week's episode of